Global Warning.
According to NASA, 2016 is
on track to be the hottest year
in history, beating the previous
record holder, 2015.
Climate change appears to be
turning into a global crisis,
kind of like dabbing
or putting kale in salads.
Uh, you're not supposed
to eat kale, by the way--
it's like (bleep) parsley,
you guys. Stop eating it.
It's not-it's not good. So
take your kids to see the snow
for the last time,
then get to higher ground,
where you'll be safe.
Comedians, I would like you
to give me as many
global warming survival tips
as you can in 60 seconds,
and begin. Steve.
Dry and jerk your turds
to eat later.
The guy who made
the guitar gun--
-he probably knows
how to do that. -AGEE: Sure.
Uh, points to Steve.
Dave.
-Pretend it's not happening.
-All right, points.
-Yeah, I said it.
-Points. You're not afraid.
Steve.
-Suck up to Elon Musk.
-All right, points.
J.
Get used to the taste
of your own urine.
Yes, points. Steve.
Get all Purgey.
All right, points. Dave.
Load up on SPF 4,000.
All right, points. J.
Learn to breathe carbon dioxide.
Yes, points. Steve.
Surround yourself
with fat, slow people, Chris.
-(bleep).
-Poi...
Points. J.
Fatten up your kids
to use as a raft.
Yeah, points.
Points.
Dave.
Weld spikes to your Prius
for when the world
goes full-on Mad Max.